you want to wait for
Roger
okay hi guys well let's see we are
continuing with another version 14
design review this is third round of our
sound and vision
design so let's get started
here all right you have your
documentation updated as well recently
how recently
l two hour last hour two hours let's do
it again okay
uh
okay
so so this is this whole question about
whether we should return a label Matrix
or whether we should do other things
here yes and image
cases
uh
okay open the page for image cases once
your docs are
updated I think those examples I've
added are convincing and I agree very
useful cases for segmented
images
okay
okay let me see
here I mean it's pretty o it's pretty
opaque doing this I mean clearly just
masked image on its own should give this
result not um if if you agree we can we
I think we should come back to this
property specification consistency maybe
in an LCC meeting I had a section on
that in the design review notebook but I
I think we have more than one hour
between me and Charles um I don't
disagree with you I think you're right
we should simplify it but there is some
inconsistency between functions as
well yeah I mean for right now the fact
that we're able to carve out the puppy
so to speak is really important yep and
we don't want to hide that behind a
totally obscure set of
options
true I'm I'm okay to update this one
function to get the shortcut syntax but
I rather prefer we look at all the
functions that take property
specification
okay so what this image actually is that
that cat that dog is a yeah it's it's a
it's an image that's a rectangular image
but it has what it has an alpha Channel
it has do color separate on it well okay
I could just do
okay
okay the silhouette of the dog mhm and
then if you scroll down any
what did it do here what happened here
so this was the fourth Channel this the
alpha no I understand that but why do
these other ones show background
here because they still have the
background red green and
blue so I don't understand why the alpha
Channel
being zero you're thinking you're
thinking maybe we
multiply it so that it kills that data
no I don't understand why did it why is
it white behind the dog rather than
black behind the
dog
because why is the alpha Channel white
when the dog
exists no no intensity zero intensity
I'm saying here why is this background I
would have thought that when you have an
alpha channel that says go to zero
opacity oh I see Zero opacity you see
the white background of the notebook
yeah okay so it's going to zero opacity
is the basic Point
yes so if I go to this and I say Edge de
detect this puppy and I mean puppy
literally
beautiful okay and it's not somehow
picking up background it's really doing
it taking account of the alpha Channel
and everything will do that is that
correct I feel lucky that Ed detected
this I I feel like we still have to make
sure Alpha Channel handling is correctly
doing this operation in every
function okay all right that's one of
those other LCC things on my list well I
haven't got to you're
not yep yeah right this is like
consistent consistent not consistent
design consistent implement
yeah
okay so question here yeah there was a
discussion last time about property
criteria format do we want to add those
to image components and when I looked at
it more closely if we return a label
Matrix for um image components one
argument and two argument then all of a
sudden property and those other
arguments require that we return
something like that one goes to Value
one two goes to Value two so the
structure of the output changes
significantly sorry if what happens if
he add the property argument to image
components itself not not to image
cases then all of a sudden we have to go
from a label Matrix to that list of
rules well I mean if we give you know
something we've done quite often in
recent times is if there's a property
that's different the structure of the
output could be different
um
okay I really don't think that's the
other thing the other thing I couldn't
figure out right away is that what is a
label Matrix what's that default output
that we have it didn't quite fit into
any property or format of any
sort well would we just call it label
Matrix I mean quotes label label Matrix
the property yeah I would think so I
don't know what what other things do we
have that have that
return you know manipulate label
matrices uh what other functions select
component delete components or delete
border components those are the ones
that manipulate label M and highlight my
image that uses it
right well so what does delete
components do delete border components
deletes components that are adjacent to
the border of the image delet small
components automatically finds a size
threshold deletes the smaller components
I know I mean but I'm I'm trying to
remember but that just does
it yeah I mean it's just doing directly
on the image forget that the label
Matrix is somewhere deep inside could
could accept the label Matrix as well
for binary images we compute connected
components but for something like Sam
we'll have to compute the connected
components I don't I'm sorry this is an
image to image function that's an image
to image or label Matrix to label Matrix
we should have examples yeah that third
basic
example okay
great and I see so on a pure okay so
what's your point now so image
components doesn't sound like something
you apply to a label Matrix could you
you could you could presumably apply it
to a label Matrix if you wanted
to why not what would it doation well
it's a segmentation
thing to a label but the label Matrix
lab matx ones and zeros it's just a
black and white
image and I'm kind of making this up but
but you know you could let's say it's
piece of
typography and it's either black or
white and it's like three letters
written
out couldn't image components on the
label Matrix then turn those three
separate components that are all just
ones initially something different I
don't know that's not a very good idea
never mind that's a bad
idea I just don't really like the name
image components for that function I
think it should be called you know image
label Matrix or
something
image I
mean I just think it's a if it's really
giving a label matrix it's a much more
specific thing and it's not really an
image to image operation which is what I
would expect if it's called image
blah the other segmentation functions
that return a label Matrix are ending
with the word
components if what I'm like Watershed
components clustering components yeah
well they don't our find the
STS I mean if it was image segmentation
components or something I'd be more you
know happier with it it's a more
technical function that's the point this
is not a function that is a an immed Med
use consumer function it's a function
that's part of an image processing
pipeline I like image segmentation
components comments on it it's more
technical sounding and it is more
technical it's pretty long so what but
yeah Roger I think that sounds good okay
tells you what it
means right otherwise otherwise what the
hell is the you
know
I mean and by by adding by ending it
with components you're saying the
convention is that returns a label
Matrix so then that's what it's going to
do
uhhuh and potentially we could have an
image segmentation that does something
different and has more of these kinds of
things yeah
okay
okay now that we are here so we talked
about image cases image Contents I think
we like that the one question there is
that now we have an object detector as
well as an object segmentation
method um and in fact in fact just
recently we released YOLO V8 for Segment
segmenting objects and I was wondering
if you look at that image cases notebook
in the middle I was wondering some kind
of a method goes to a detection method
segmentation method would make sense
going forward I don't understand what
what difference does it make to the
person who's picking out the
puppy well it's different backends
different methods do you want to segment
using Sam or do you want to using the
same I just want the puppy how do I get
the
puppy I don't care it's up to us to
figure out whether we Sam it or YOLO it
or YOLO it no no method you want to be
exposed well no we can expose a method
but I don't rely on that method I mean
we got to do it the best way we can sure
the default the default will do the best
but I'm asking if you want to expose the
method should we do it as sub options of
method like like an associ why why is it
a sub option because there's two of them
the the detection that gives us the
bounding
box could use different methods than the
segmentation that gives us the mask well
then you got to give an association then
you got method Arrow associate you know
segmentation method and and you know
like she's done she's done it there yeah
what's that that that's on the
screen oh that's exactly what you
already did yeah well I agree okay
great all right image component detect
is a function that returns a mask for
the whole
image it's effectively the alpha channel
of remove background as I say there well
it now has to be image segmentation
component detect which is a bit
long
but if you open that ref page some other
name proposals we had like image
component mask do we want to call it
image segmentation mask yes
image yes segment detector segment
mask image semantic you ruled out last
time correctly so I forgot to remove
that as an
alternative image segment Mass I like I
yeah segment well Im segmentation mask
yeah but
that's I mean do we have other functions
that sort of do a whole image
masking like
this uh image saliency filter the filter
functions that we have are doing a whole
image filtering they mostly end with
filter and saliency is the only one that
gives a big region the other ones H
image segmentation filter doesn't sound
totally crazy to
me what is marker what does marker mean
here specify by
marker marker can be a
point on on the White Horse or could be
a bounding box a rectangle around the
horse or could be multiple points on the
White Horse and the brown horse horse so
wait a minute so then I would get both a
white and a brown yeah true yeah a mask
for both of those objects
yes one mask that represents both of
those
objects okay but then then this is
really is a filter because what it's
doing is you
know I mean it's a little bit weird
because I could imagine something which
just says give me a horse and it would
give me a a mask for the whole image
which just picks out a horse but this is
doing something different this is saying
you're giving it a place in the image
and it's puffing out to the object that
is so indicated is that correct yes so
that's a really different kind of thing
and that's not you know image
segmentation components is just like
give me all the various components right
correct so this is really a different
thing this is an image you know it's an
object filter so to
speak yeah segment filter object
filter segment filter because really we
don't have a notion of objects in these
segmentation these
are
semantically as you identified they're
really not necessarily connected no I
mean I don't know this seems like a
pretty technical
function yeah as I say in that last
bullet point I think
like functions like in paint could use
it so you may want to identify the
region first and then pass it to in
paint we have functions that take
masking
options like you have an image with
uneven illumination you want a mask you
could imagine that that second argument
could be
horse yes the prompting is not ready for
14 but we're definitely yeah it's in
that table so if if that's the case if
we can put a horse there as well as a
position I think image segmentation
filter is okay
okay
Roger yeah sounds good why do you want
to call it filter instead of mask
because I because we got other things
that are called
filter which do this this exact
operation do they not yeah image
saliency filter is really similar yeah
except that it has a gray
level and and and I think it's fine I
think image segmentation filter could
also return with some other methods
there are very many image matting
methods that return a gray scale and
filter is in fact the more proper name
for that
function
okay masks are usually binary
yes all right so the question here we're
injecting Sam into remove
background um in remove background we
don't have methods we have
models the question is that this s based
segmentation what should it be called
what model should it be called initially
I named it
semantic all of these tables are it
might be easier if you go to that remove
background new that is linked from the
top of the
notes CU that's a more cleaned up
version of
it where sorry the top of the notes of
remove background notebook that was
well me can I just go just just
yeah so see those string models like
blurred and bright and dark now I added
semantic and semantic with some
parameters which is which is the wrong
term I know crazy I mean but and it's
wrong for S based methods anyways but
what do I call it just Sam on segment
criteria for separating foreground and
background
are what does this mean blood
region so we could say give me the
background that is blurred give me a
background that is bright give me the
background or foreground that's
Salient well the background is not
salent give me the foreground remove
background is giving me only what's sent
so see the first table we have spec for
both foreground and background and
depending on images it's sometimes
easier to specify foreground
characteristics and sometimes it's
easier to specify background
characteristics well then why don't you
have a thing called UNS
Salient
okay well the syntax supports for both
and it's really a one minus the other
one whatever is computed well I
understand but but but I mean we need
to given that you're doing this and you
have bright and dark you surely should
have Salient and UNS
Salient uhhuh sure I can add
that
okay so
this I mean this is really an
object-based thing isn't
it this thing here mysterious what Sam
is what's that
it's it's a bit mysterious what Sam is
right with the parameters again we can
we can say let let's call this model Sam
for the time being it
what does Sam stand for Segment anything
model that
before let's see there's a question on a
live stream from Sand what happens if it
is semi-transparent I'm lost what it is
unfortunately I I think this came when
we were talking about Alpha channel of
um sub images in image
cases yes so if if we get segmentation
methods that give us grayscale masks we
see through that mask some of the
background and may what Sandra is
talking about is what if the image that
you're trying to segment out is itself
semi-transparent does it get tangled
up I don't think so because if the mask
is either it's all there or it's not
there
for remove background we're multiplying
the back the detected background with
the original so we're usually trying not
to look at anything in the masked area
the alpha channel is already
masking the
image okay in terms of bright dark
whatever
um you know I feel like it's almost on
object off object
you know where is the background where
is the foreground it's on this
object but I don't know I mean you know
also also look at the parameters that I
suggest that model can take which can be
positioned prompts again like pores um
rectangles and
stuff yeah yeah objectness or well I
don't know I don't know because I also
don't like particularly this list and I
think I I also think that foreground
background
thing is sort of
wrong and I think it should be more
foreground Arrow
whatever and and can you have both
foreground and
background um we had the idea that we
could have both of them we never
implemented
that they they could run into each other
to say you know foreground Arrow
background arrow and even in an
association for
example I think that's a that's a syntax
we can easily support it doesn't clash
with what we have
now yeah I mean implementation wise if
we
specify characteristics for both of them
they may run into each other and then
we'll have to come up with her istics
how to yeah but but okay but with this
Sam based
thing just generic Sam means if it's an
object make it
foreground right that's what it that's
what it's basically saying yes
uh I mean so I think it's objects versus
non-objects that's the you know the
background is non-objects
and then it has to be objects
comma you know I mean do we have any
other term for the things that are being
recognized in image cases for example
other than objects like horses and
things in image cases it's really mainly
referred to as object detection okay
fine so I would say objects and
nonobjects and then non Salient and
nonobjects you would cam case with ons
being big yeah capital
okay it's fine seems fine to me okay and
I mean for now I guess these list
syntaxes are okay
okay not my total favorite but
okay
okay I I think we like this last time so
no yeah no news
here
oh my mouse keeps on dying
terrible
okay um the fact that find image shapes
can accept label matrices at first point
also I think we talked about we'll try
to get it into
14 um and I think image segmentation
components is going to uh be a very good
label Matrix for that purpose the other
thing we talked about was that sort of a
automatic
pre-processing and then uh with Roger we
thought perhaps a good name for such an
option could be pre-processing function
we already have pre-processing rules
that we use in
wordcloud seems like a good companion
for gosh haven't don't we have things
like pre-processing functions and a
bunch of machine learning
stuff I even if we do it's not a symbol
and Julio confirmed that we can use that
option in many other places as well then
let's have it it's a good idea
okay H detect with segment anything
edges um I'm suggesting we just come
back to it at least post 14 really most
of the time Edge detection is used for
segmentation or or maybe for like
creative effects and things like that
and it seems a little besides the point
to convert the segmentation to edges
yeah at that point so we'll postpone
that if you find usefulness for it we'll
bring it back later okay um similar
question in text recognize as I had it
for image cases U there as well we have
a text detector versus Tex recognizer
text recognizer so in a method
option if you scroll down a
little past everything I guess we could
have a similar Association
of detector backends and recognizer
backends
I mean are we really going to have these
named that's that was my second question
it doesn't look pretty because these are
really the backend engines that we
use but how else can we be
specific I wouldn't call it operating
system I would call it native or
something native okay or Os Os native
something like that I don't know I'm not
sure because I don't even know what
that
[Music]
um so what happens if you just give one
method option method
Arrow I I think we can easily support
that so if we say for for things like
eocr which are support that both which
are doing both detection and recognition
it can just be that one string but for
other for other combinations we can also
just pick the other one
automatically yeah but I mean in in
um
okay but so what's the
default um the best we can find for
natural scene um documents or images we
are uh doing we are using dbet as a
detector and our own trained recognizer
well from OCR we we want and then for
documents we are still using Tesseract
but with benchmarks we're doing with
those easy OCR I think we can switch to
that but I'm still waiting on full
Benchmark
results okay label Matrix
workflows yeah that's something that
Roger asked me to put together just just
for us to see when label matrices become
annoying to work with and it's really
that very long Edge on the right that
has bugged
you when when we want to combine the
result of yeah so we segment get label
Matrix we can do measurements on it
display it and all of that it only gets
annoying when you want to do some
measurements or selection where you need
both the label Matrix and the
image and how do we fix
that um annotations I think can help
yeah and that's something we're going to
be working on post 14 well basically the
label Matrix is just an overlay on the
image yes yeah I think it's the right
thing to do I mean I think label
matrices honestly label matrices seem to
me like fourr like
constructs you know and they really
should be something that is just a
metadata of the image
MH all right are we ready to go on to
the next segment talking
segmentation Charles did you send me the
next
segment hello
Charles sorry I was on mute
um you mean the notebook I thought it
was in the agenda okay I'm sending it
right
now
I think it is in the agenda okay I can
get it there but easier
it when are we going to get uh course
screening of graphs for display
for bigger apps you mean
yeah
um well we've done some preliminary
experiments I don't think we have
something conclusive
yet maybe you could share those with
some of the people who are working on
phics project because we need that stuff
and we can build some
prototypes Mak
sense I I mean I think there are many
ways to do it and we might as well
experiment with things but make some
wfrs those kinds of things
MH Charles okay Charles can you can you
handle
that um
sure I mean
is is this it seems to be too General
but but but sure I just whatever you
have I mean I it's like we've got you
know there's a whole big hper graph
effort that's being done and hypergraph
visualization and so on and you know I
think that effort should be able to deal
with C graining of graphs and whatever
you have I'd like to get those guys to
work with given that you're not pushing
that forward you know this month type
thing and see what they can
produce why I mean yes and I mean we we
we have a significant amount actually
already in the system doing the spring
electrical I mean that's what it does
actually behind the scene great but it's
it's just you just need to explain what
you've done and then we'll see whether
people can take it further even when
you're not specifically working on this
all right now what do we want to look at
here the hyperbolic embedding wasn't
working last
time yes and it's still not working
there is there are some defect I'm still
working on try to figure out why it's
happening okay all right so what should
we look at guide us through this agenda
please well from the last sry go go
ahead you no go ahead Charles I mean
from from the last meeting we we went to
everything you just pointed out if I
remember correctly the hyperbolic
embedding you wanted to understand more
as well as the spherical texture mapping
I think those were the two key points
all right okay so let's look at those I
mean I mean just guid me through what we
need to do I mean this is
your okay so Roger or Charles just tell
me what we need to be looking at yeah so
you wanted to understand more about sort
of these uh so if you go to the texture
new
page and they these are standard texture
mappings it's not the end of texture
mapping but these are standard texture
mappings and what's new is both the
support Prim that don't have vertex
texture
coordinates okay hold
on let me try to understand this so a
texture is generally given as a re as a
rectangular region with pixels in it
correct
yes okay and that rectangular region is
a UV space of some
kind yes and you got to map that onto
the Sur surface of an object yes which
is a story of coordinate charts and
other such Adventures
yes okay so now the question is what are
those coordinate charts what is you know
given so these parameters assume that
the parameters u and v vary I don't what
do you assume from 0 to one from bottom
left to top right type
thing yes sorry hello was that a yes
yes
okay
[Music]
um okay so part of what we wanted to
improve is the documentation here maybe
to explain and maybe in some cases
provide
parameters
so what we had before this has six
coordinate chart this has the coordinate
chart is broken into six pieces in this
case it's reused six times right whereas
in this case there's a single chart
yes
and and
in you know maybe it doesn't sh maybe
the illustration is not the greatest but
cubic it's it's reused also six times
but there sort of the question is how
flipped they are yep I
understand I think that the way to
indicate flipping would be to draw the
coordinate draw the pad underneath with
somehow an arrow going the other way or
alternatively to not use something which
is um uh you know symmetrical as the
image right I mean if you put an arrow
on the image inside the
image that might be helpful even if it's
only in those cases of the of the box
and the cubic
case
yeah okay I I think I do understand this
and this is pretty nice and I I
understand that if you have a a thing
that's the shape of a you know if you're
mapping onto a a do aedin for example I
don't know which of these you use I mean
what happens if I do that if I take if I
take this well if I take oh Christ my
mouse died you you can do that yeah how
do I get that thing there o there I see
why can't I see it why can't I well that
is an image obviously just copy it yeah
I know but but why can't oh because it
just those colors are just interact
badly okay so there it is so now let me
say so now I want to put this on a doic
hedrin so I say graphics 3D of
texture of blah
comma comma the mapping the map so so
let's say I say
stereographic the mapping is not yet
supported at this time in the protot
build correct use
right right well so how do I do
this um so if you close the bracket and
then you put
Aon and right now you do Vex texture Cod
it goes to the
mapping
well as an as an option in Dota
CAD aray Arrow oops well let's start off
with the
stereographic but it's not there there
not one on
the well so that's why I say if it's
right there use but it's not on the
table but everything is not yet
implemented so we are still working on
those so don't expect that it will work
or we have support of those additional
option on data
Chron amazingly worked but it You
misspelled
it well I don't know what the hell it's
stereographic I don't know what it's
doing I don't know what texture it's
using it's using some random texture map
here let's try for
example uh
cylindrical unless nothing works
I don't understand that
picture I don't understand
that I mean it's amusing but I don't
understand
it it looks
like planer maybe if I were to guess
from
the that does look like
box I mean the cylindrical is correct is
just that is a cylinder so the
production as you see that it's picking
on the
top oh what do you mean where's the
cylinder is the
cylinder which way is the doc Eden
wrapped in a cylinder looks like it's
wrapped horizontally in the cylinder and
this is kind of its its North Pole that
gets
funky I don't understand why the
cylinder comes up to triangular points
at the North Pole
um if I go cubic here I suspect I'll get
the same as box won't
I yeah okay so those are you know if I
look at that face it's deformed by the
projection by the fact that it is a
projected projected onto the nonflat
dhedin face from the rectal linear box
correct
yes
yes I don't know what plane that does
let's try
that okay I don't understand that what's
that
doing it looks like it's projecting from
the top down yeah but for some reason
it's transparent in the middle because
it it
goes okay so for example if I to project
that onto a
cube then the edges of the cube would
have yeah good great that's nice yeah
that's what I would expect try a
cylinder for that guy because
[Music]
I'm unrotated it too just because I
didn't know what you did with
there that's
weird wonder which way got corser I
because the
cylinder which way is the cylinder put
yeah I I know it's not pointing this way
it's it's wrapping the other way right
it's wrapping not around the equator but
around the you know
Meridian
yeah or maybe maybe it's a much simpler
explanation maybe it wasn't even doing
that it was not implemented yet so it
just picked
L Yu is here which which so youu what
what's the story with this um might not
be might might be just a
bug well you got some test cases
here oh boy that's
weird yeah I don't understand
that um the Computing based on that the
shape is a
spherical uh object and if it is not
trying to
warp a little bit I know I understand
that but I don't understand the
warping I mean that warping is rather
extreme so let's say we go with a um
uh well try a sphere spherical I'm just
wondering
yeah
oh because it doesn't have
vertices oh add z z z z Oh
yeah maybe come on one just
here okay that sort of looks veral I
shouldn't need those that's a bug right
that I needed those do you agree yeah
it's it's not yet fully implemented yep
should just work but that look like
spherical to me little bit weirder at
the top what's
that the Bottom's okay yeah top yeah the
top is fixed it's just not picked up
yet try a cylindrical on that guy
because I think that one can predict
from that doing
yeah
well that's kind of what I would have
expected but it didn't work for the for
the um so just just so I understand how
do I make a how do I take an ad doic
aedin and augment it to just give it
many more faces otherwise spherize it
you know what I'm saying augmented what
is that called polyhedrin augmented
polyhedron or something what is that
called yeah we have the mented poons
it's it's not subdividing is that
subdividing
faces um yes some so
for let's say we take
this and um well let's just do the
sperical
case because that should approximate a
sphere am my
right so then here I want to do
this
oh that's bad how do I do
this that shouldn't be that way that
should work right yes we are still
propagating the support on all graphic
Primitives as well as contor so you see
all right okay all right what else is
there for us to look at
here I think that this was the main
thing or did I forget something Charles
no that was that was just the main thing
yeah I think that the texture thing was
was where we got hung up okay
unfortunately not F nice I think what
you're doing there looks nice I mean
there's some bugs but it looks like
really nice concept really
useful um
and cool and lots of nice examples that
could be given from
it yeah uh actually let me just try one
more thing Let me just
try so I understand what's happening if
I go to front
here I don't really know why the front
is the
top that's got to be a bug it's just got
to be a implemented yet
oh so from front does planer or
something it didn't do it
just is what youu said okay but still
the orientation is some is somewhat
funky or
whatever I mean I do think that this
question about which way is
up all of these things have a which way
is up
definition
yes and
uh if feels a little bit
arbitrary but I guess it sort of has to
be but
but but once I have the you know which
way is up in what coordinate
system so I'm saying let's say the
cylindrical is is up in the Z Direction
you
know which who's Z
direction is it user coordinate so what
what the heck is
it do you understand my question
question yeah well I mean it's going to
be in the global coordinate system for
sure which is user coordinates not
screen coordinates or anything like that
yes
yes so this sphere if I turn the sphere
upside
down by
modifying
this uh up up is still the same I think
it has to be the same yeah I understand
because it's in user coordinates
yes
[Music]
um okay
and well I just wanted to add that
actually most of them should in
principle or will coincide with our
coordinate transform because it's more
coordinate transformation between two
system what do you mean by
that that mean for example you know if
you do coordinate transform of c um what
C goes to
cylindrical right and you you know you
actually compute manually the v test
your coordinate you should
match right so there is an explicit
transform it's not
a hand waving operation for
me sorry I I was spaced out from it
could you repeat that so I mean as we
are working with you know through
this the transformation or the
projection here in principle will match
with coordinate transform transformation
I that's the name of the function we
have here coordinate transform so for
example if you do transform of cian goes
to
cylindrical yeah you should get the
actual formula which will map with yes I
agree here so presumably any of the
coordinate systems provided there would
be a possible
mapping in principle yes I don't see why
we shouldn't do that I mean it should be
easy to do right once you have
these it's I mean flowing through those
what is it coordinate do coordinate
systems what is it called how do we get
I was talking about coordinate oh the
the list I'm not
sure oh come on
how do we get to
this let's see whether I've wanted
suchar system actually
works it's Cate chart data I
believe okay can somebody please report
this as yet another bad search
result yeah I can do
that yes another
okay well any one of these should be
usable I don't see why not I mean it
seems like we get it for free if we're
just using this technology
stack but well the question is is it
really
useful for graphics and there is a c to
implement to is there I mean I would
assume that you're just going through
the pipeline it's going on gpus
Stephen I
see I have no idea conle might be useful
I don't
know I mean we don't have an automatic I
mean we these formulas are not that
complicated I mean don't we have an
automatic way to compile them with the
GPU we we can look into this for the
next version defitely yeah okay I mean
given that you're saying it works just
like coordinate
transforms let's have it follow
coordinate transform so to
speak yep we working on that to make
sure
the pr much
yeah but looks nice all right anything
else we need to cover NOP that's it all
right thank you very much and uh thank
you is that is that it for your teams
Roger yep that's it that concludes
14 good stuff all right see y all soon
see you
then